Chris Hemsworth doesn't want to return to
"the place where no man has gone before."
In an in-depth interview with Variety, he
revealed the real reason he turned down the
chance to reprise his role as George Kirk
in Star Trek 4.
Hemsworth's Star Trek character ...the father
of Chris Pine's James T. Kirk ...only appeared
in the opening sequence of J.J. Abrams' 2009
Star Trek reboot ...and his character seemingly
perished after the Romulans attacked the Federation
starship USS Kelvin.
"Sweetheart, can you hear me?"
"I can hear you."
"I love you so much.
I love…"
Ever since then, franchise fans have wondered
whether the fallen officer will ever pop up
again in a future installment.
Unfortunately, it sounds like that isn't going
to happen anytime soon.
Hemsworth told Variety that he turned down
the chance to star in Star Trek 4 because
he didn't find the script particularly intriguing
or satisfying.
More importantly, it sounds like he didn't
think the storyline ultimately earned the
character's return.
As he put it,
"I didn't feel like we landed on a reason
to revisit that yet.
I didn't want to be underwhelmed by what I
was going to bring to the table."
What's interesting about these comments is
how they contradict an announcement Paramount
Pictures made about Hemsworth's involvement
in Star Trek 4.
In 2016, the studio claimed the actor would
be returning to Star Trek 4, as would Chris
Pine.
That announcement read in part:
"In the next installment of the epic space
adventure, Chris Pine's Captain Kirk will
cross paths with a man he never had a chance
to meet [...] his father.
Chris Hemsworth, who appeared in 2009's Star
Trek, will return to the space saga as George
Kirk to star alongside Pine."
Between then and now, Hemsworth backed out
of the film ...as did Pine, evidently.
In August 2018, The Hollywood Reporter ran
a story that claimed both actors parted ways
with Paramount and Skydance Media after the
companies reportedly backtracked on promised
deals.
Following the disappointing box office performance
of Star Trek Beyond, Paramount reportedly
modified Hemsworth and Pine's deals in such
a way that they both would've had to take
significant pay cuts.
Perhaps money was the major issue for both
Chrises, but for Hemsworth, it evidently wasn't
the only factor that led him to walk away
from Star Trek 4.
Though it would've been truly amazing to see
Hemsworth return to the franchise, we understand
why he ultimately declined.
Based on his statements, it sounds like he'd
still be interested in reprising the role
for a future installment ...just as long as
the script was super-solid.
But based on what Hemsworth told Variety,
it sounds like the way George Kirk would've
figured into the storyline of Star Trek 4
was shaky at best.
What's more, Hemsworth has become a household
name thanks to playing Thor in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
At this point, it sounds like he only wants
to sign on to projects that he truly feels
passionate about.
Since he's one of the hottest names in Hollywood
right now, he must be getting dozens of offers
on the hour.
At the end of the day, Star Trek 4 simply
didn't tickle the Aussie actor's fancy, and
that's okay.
It's not like he'll be out of work without
it.
Sadly, Star Trek 4 may ultimately never get
off the ground.
In April 2018, Paramount greenlit production
on two Star Trek features: one from Quentin
Tarantino, and one from British television
director S.J.
Clarkson.
But less than a year later, it was reported
that Star Trek 4 was, quote, "cancelled indefinitely."
Even though the studio pulled the plug on
the project, plenty of fans are still holding
out hope that Paramount will eventually bring
Star Trek 4 back to life.
But even if they do decide to resurrect the
film, don't expect to see Hemsworth's pretty
face anywhere in the film.
"Sweetheart, listen to me.
I'm not gonna be there."
"No."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.